[Music]
in Guanajuato Mexico there is a museum
filled entirely with mummies
[Music]
mi nombre es palomero vez la que yo yo
le directeur Adel museo de las mamiya's
de guanajuato el museo de las Diez de
guanajuato es un resent o sagrado kxe
hay una collection pneumonias naturalist
with 117 bodies in total the museum has
the largest collection of natural
mummies in the world
the mummies are the well-preserved
remains of people who died during a
cholera outbreak in Mexico in the 1800s
the museum is a haunting and eerie
experience for visitors an opportunity
to stare death in the face
Veeran a buscar s experiencia intima sa
encuentro místico con la muerte k
propecia la repression enter no a la
intención su propia vida
yes NGO de la misma es importante que
las personas no tengan miedo la muerte
yell contrary oh no bear oboe phenomena
natural como una transición inevitable
existential porque finalmente saber en
contrar Konoha
[Music]
there's the rulers the reverb tank the
e-book
[Music]
a normal instrument you're playing it
and you're expecting it to have a sound
that is pleasing but with an instrument
like this the goal is to just produce
sounds that in this case are disturbing
[Music]
the apprehension engine was an
instrument that creates a variety of
really creepy and someone say horrifying
sounds my name is Mark Corvin I'm a film
music composer and lately I've been
focusing on horror movie scores two of
my biggest hits as far as horror films
are concerned was from the late 90s a
film called cube and most recently the
which I originally commissioned the
apprehension Asian because I was tired
and the same digital samples which which
resulted in a lot of sameness of a lot
of horror music so I was looking for
something more experimental more
acoustic that would give me a little bit
more of an original sound that's where I
contacted my friend Tony Duggan Smith so
Marc called me asking me to create a
crazy instrument for horror films
because I've never done anything like
that before
it may be empty out my pockets and all
my drawers of any knickknacks and bits
and bobs I could possibly string
together to make it happen for him and
this is what came of it
[Music]
you're doing those things that stir it
primal motions and the feelings and
there actually is a skill set that you
have to acquire in order to to get the
most out of it
it expresses what really can't be
expressed any other way it's not music
in the traditional sense at all but let
me put it this way the apprehension
engine definitely evokes an emotion so I
would call it easy
[Music]
[Music]
every night countless people wake up
unable to move their minds and bodies in
the throes of a real condition called
sleep paralysis when triggered the
symptoms are usually mild from tense
muscles to laboured breathing but for
some the experience conjures
hallucinations that make nightmares come
alive here are some of their stories
[Music]
before I learned to cope with it I've
seen quite a few awful things horror
films don't really they don't really do
anything for me anymore because what
I've seen is more terrifying the
earliest I can remember is seeing a
figure that looked like my mother
sitting on my bed
her face is then morphing into some kind
of demon another time a little girl was
in the corner just just staring at me
then without notice she shrieks and runs
up and grabs me by the neck
you try to call for help but your voice
it it doesn't work and your body won't
respond you just you just you just feel
helpless on one particular night I felt
like someone was looking at me from the
foot of my bed I knew that nothing was
there but I was afraid to open my eyes
when I did I saw a woman's head looking
straight back at me she didn't have a
body or even a neck just her head I
still remember the smirk she had on her
face I closed my eyes immediately and I
was unable to move when I felt it was
safe I open my eyes again
[Music]
she was still there and she began to
laugh at me I closed my eyes again
hoping she would disappear then I heard
this scoff and she was gone so I
remember waking up and feeling a
presence in the room and I see this
woman in a black dress looming above the
floor and she kept coming closer and
closer to me I could feel my throat
closing I I couldn't breathe as soon as
she made it towards me she floated right
in front of my face and started
screaming I bolted out of my bed and I
tried to wake up my parents little did I
know I was still dreaming and I ended up
back in my bed in another sleep
paralysis experience it's something that
it's so wild and surreal that there's no
logic to it so if you wake up one day
paralyzed by horrific visions remember
to stay calm and understand that your
nightmares are only as real as you make
them
Winchester Mystery House in San Jose
California is one of the most haunted
places in America Winchester Mystery
House is a incredibly unique Victorian
mansion created by Sarah Winchester
heiress to the Winchester Repeating Arms
fortune Sarah Winchester had a series of
unfortunate things happened to her
including the death of her husband and
daughter she was a spiritualist and
visited a medium to try and understand
why the medium said well the gun the one
the West there's a lot of karma there so
head west and build a house to appease
these spirits she started construction
in 1884 and what she didn't stop until
the day she died the house is a hundred
and sixteen room Victorian mansion is no
master plan there's a lot of strange
attributes there's 40 staircases 40
fireplaces four elevators we have a
number of staircases that lead right to
the ceiling doors that open up into
nothing or it's just a wall the house is
known for its spirits who many people
believe are the ghosts of people who
worked at the house or even Sarah
herself a lot of our guests and
employees have had very strange things
happen to them
this house sometimes it's just footsteps
or hearing a voice the life that
flickers or sometimes it's an actual
full physical manifestation if we
haven't solved the mysteries in 93 years
then I don't know if we ever this
sculpture garden located in Japan was
primarily unknown to the world until
2016 when a photographer stumbled upon
it
[Music]
they're around 800 sculptures in this
park depicting a mix of Buddhist deities
and what I believed to be replicas of
real people all were commissioned by a
wealthy Japanese man named Matsui
Furukawa he is said to have paid 6
billion yen around 60 million u.s.
dollars to create this collection in
1989 there is a large statue of Furukawa
which stands overlooking the park the
people depicted are said to be his
friends and family but it is unclear if
they had any knowledge of their stony
replicas they stand near a Japanese
village the name of which translates to
the village where you can meet Buddhist
statues although these life like statues
stare with blank expressions visitors
say there is an unsettling feeling to
this place and a concern that at night
these effigies answer still
I think like everybody I'm interested in
stories about ghosts or
extraterrestrials some people would say
well don't explain that don't explain
that I want to believe that people call
me a debunker they say I'm trying to
disprove I'm raining on their parade and
you know what I don't apologize at all
for trying to find the truth and Joe
Nickell from the committee for skeptical
inquiry we've invited renowned skeptic
Joe Nickell to meet Cora Lorenzo this
this medieval superstition has got to go
and this is really just I'm Joe Nickell
and I'm a paranormal investigator I
investigate everything from monsters
ghosts aliens psychics for a science
organization and the magazine skeptical
Inquirer I knew at the age of eight that
I was a detective but I eventually
became a stage magician oh my goodness
my models were Harry Houdini and other
magicians who used their magic talents
to expose trickery and meanwhile like
everybody I was curious about haunted
houses and flying saucers and I decided
I wanted to do something like that I've
written about 40 books primarily on
mysteries a lot of cases were miracle
claims or some kind of religious claims
spontaneous human combustion Lake
Monster mysteries crop circles UFO
sighting chupacabras ghosts Bigfoot
[Music]
what I'm trying to do is actually
investigate looking for facts and clues
as you begin to put together a case
finally you fill the file folder with
what data you have and then trying to
find actually corroborating evidence so
that I can try to explain what's
happening explain a UFO sighting my
explanations are often quite mundane
people report seeing these long-necked
multi humped lake monsters there are
many things that can create the illusion
of a lake monster including two or three
or four otters swimming in line which
create the effect of one large creature
Bigfoot is a tall hairy bipedal creature
there is a creature that looks very much
like Bigfoot that is a black bear or a
brown bear standing sniffing the air and
walking about people driving by when old
mentioned in the little community of
Burt New York sometimes reported seeing
a ghostly figure dressed in white as it
turns out they had had a mannequin
dressed in white in the window and that
was responsible for many of those
sightings I think part of me would like
for there to be ghosts and for there to
be extraterrestrials but I've done this
a long time and I'm pretty sure that
ghosts don't exist even the skeptics who
like what I do will often their first
reaction is that's pretty obvious
everything is obvious after it's been
explained
you